citizens of reject Nation I have seen
all of those comments of oh koi likes
everything and he just there are things
I don't like so I thought today we would
go through the 10 May 11 worst or
perhaps just most disappointing
superhero movies of all time before we
get to that please do leave a like
subscribe hit that Bell to get notified
maybe we'll do a best of list maybe you
wanted to get notified of that maybe you
need to hit that Bell and also please do
follow me on Tick Tock for all sorts of
comic book goodness I broke that Matt
Reeves news before a lot of outlets
because I have my finger on the pulse
and I'm very excited speaking of finger
on the pulse let's talk bad superhero
movies let's go
I had to include this on the list making
at 11 it was going to be a top 10 video
but it's top 11 because I remember being
so bummed because I defended Daredevil
so hard and then they made a spin-off
called Elektra and it's just not great
it's not that Jennifer Garner wasn't
impassioned it's not that they didn't
try to tie it in the special way but it
felt like the beginning of fox not
really knowing what to do with the
shared Universe it looked like they were
starting to build that was a long time
ago going to be a secret Wars s combo A
Fantastic Four Daredevil and this whole
giant thing at Fox I think Elektra was
the movie that stopped that and I think
that it's it's a shame that it's set
back email LED films a shared Universe
of films and superhero films and one
foul swoop by just not being what it
needed to be there were incredible
things to me coming out of that era
because they were building to what we
got to now but Elektra I think was a
step back I didn't think it worked and
Jennifer Garner deserved better do we
need movies with women I think I mean
they're like 51 of us should they be on
screen Greg and that 51 the weaker per
se I mean I can't have a baby and
sometimes I get a tummy cramp and I call
out of work and they have cramps every
month and babies come out of them I've
got a more modern one and this one's on
the list because I always want Indie
Comics to do well I love when Marvel and
DC do well I love when image does well
but I really want the Indie companies to
rise up too and Valiant was starting a
whole universe off of bloodshot the
thing with bloodshot is they made it a
very milk toast neutral cookie cutter it
felt like it was a superhero movie made
in the 90s in a bad way you know what
I'm gonna say the words right now and
it's going to make this whole video it
did wrong what I think morbius did right
I like that morbius wanted to be a 90s
vampire Thriller and it committed to
that I feel like bloodshot wanted to be
a 90s action movie and didn't commit
instead it made a neutral thing that
happened and you didn't engage with any
of the characters and it kind of wasted
the launch of a universe and that's
always sad because I really wanted more
out of it and I wanted to see more of
this world so it's a bummer that the the
law punch was neutral I gave there's
some positive morbius right there you
heard me come at me internet we gotta
talk about a movie that always makes the
worst of lists that is getting some love
lately which I love that it's getting
some love but it doesn't negate the
negatives right there's a movie
Spider-Man 3 and that's a sandman movie
that's a third Goblin movie that is a
movie that deals with the beautiful Arc
of Harry Osborne while dealing with the
beautiful Arc of Peter Parker
unfortunately Sony was dead set on
having Venom in this movie and that
through if you look at the things that
don't work in Spider-Man 3 it's largely
all Venom based whether it's the dancing
whether it's venom himself whether it's
the choice to do ultimate venom which is
like more of a Peter Parker Eddie rocker
parallel Choice all of those things that
don't work are largely by throwing the
kitchen sink at it the Sandman stuff is
incredible but we don't remember the
Sandman stuff I do but a lot of people
don't the pathos of Harry Osborne and
all of those things are incredible but
we don't get that because we remember
dancing so for me Spider-Man 3 makes the
most disappointing list not not because
the movie itself is bad but because we
went from Spider-Man 2 to Spider-Man 3
because major Studio powers that be
didn't trust someone who had just made
them like a billion dollars to make the
movie he wanted and I would have loved
to have seen Spider-Man 4. I would have
loved to have seen what we could have
gotten you guys know I'm outspoken as
like Toby Maguire is not exactly how I
see Spider-Man and that's okay A lot of
people do I think of Andrew Garfield as
Spider-Man when I think of Spider-Man
but even with that little caveat I would
have loved to have seen a more mature
evil evolution of Tokyo Maguire
Spider-Man like we eventually got no way
home and I think we would have gotten
that sooner if they let Sam Raimi make
the Sandman Green Goblin third
installment the way he wanted to and
that's always going to be a what could
have been and I would love black hat and
vulture and four anyway three is
disappointing because of the what could
have been it at all I want you to take
the director of one of the best James
Bond movies ever hard stop I want you to
tell me in the past that he's gonna make
a superhero movie I want you to then
tell me he's gonna cast one of your
favorite actors I also want you to tell
me in the future one of the supporting
players in this is going to be integral
directing and acting and reshaping
comedy in the modern sense of culture I
also want you to tell me that one of my
favorite actors and a person I admire
very much and how they handle themselves
on and off camera is going to meet the
love of his life on this film set and
they're gonna have beautiful children
together and they're going to be very
happy and I'm gonna go well at least
that last thing happened because the
rest didn't work for me Green Lantern is
a movie and I wish that it was a movie
that made Hal Jordan a household name I
wish it was a movie that allowed the
Green Lantern Court to be as big of a
thing as flash or Batman or Superman but
unfortunately the team behind the movie
made a lot of interesting choices to
make it so a character that invents
things through sheer willpower as played
by one of the most Charming charismatic
funny men on the planet somehow is both
boring in a way that's like what's the
next scene gonna be and that's
interesting because there's so much
going on and look like it doesn't
understand what it's trying to be there
are scenes where he invents stuff out of
his mind that he could have done
something either way simpler or way more
complicated the middle ground of like a
weird racetrack like what what is
happening here he's a jet fighter but
there's a lot of logical leaps and
there's a lot of mustache twirling in
villainy and Mark Strong is way better
than that and and I don't know it's just
it's an odd series of tones I think is
my issue I feel like that movie is about
10 tones too many if it was one or two
tones if it Blended worlds better and if
it landed in in that space cop green
lanternness it could have been a special
thing said a lot of special Parts but I
think there's a reason we needed
Deadpool
okay I'm afraid I'm so scared all right
my next one it's a recent Batman movie
I'm uncomfortable Batman vs Superman I
said it out loud I said the quiet part
out loud I do not enjoy Batman vs
Superman hey have you seen the ultimate
edition I have I have seen the ultimate
edition it is a three hour version of
the one I saw there is more Merit
absolutely there are subplots and things
that make it better much like Daredevil
with all the Coolio stuff but that
doesn't make either A or B film that I
hold these things to the standard to the
reason I'm harsh on comic book films is
because there's 70 years of Mythology
often on so many properties there's so
much backstory there's so much that you
already have done for you and yes these
are archetypal characters that you're
adapting yes it should not be a
translation but when you give Batman a
gun when you have Batman murdering
innocent people on the street when you
have Batman deciding to not be the
world's greatest detective but to just
be a brute object against an alien that
that he decides to not understand
there's a great reason in the comic
books Batman and Superman fight it takes
issues it takes Journeys it takes us
knowing these characters in the movie I
did not understand why Batman decided he
made Lex luthor-esque choices where he
was just like oh this thing is other I
don't like it I don't trust it bro you
dress like a bat you think you're normal
like it doesn't work if both characters
don't have the Integrity that they do
with arcs and build up not only that but
it hurts Henry cavill's Superman we
didn't get more Superman because we get
him in one movie a great movie I enjoy
Man of Steel his sequel it should have
been Man of Steel too it shouldn't have
been let's bring in Batman so we can
jump to the Justice League in one more
movie we literally went from step one to
step seven to step 17. that's not fair
to Henry cavill's Superman so this movie
Sidelines Superman after one movie it
makes Batman's whole Arc not make sense
the whole Martha thing I could do a
separate video about we won't go there
it's just a very common name in the 60s
amid since they both had that but we
make Lex Luthor into and the casting
Choice making it much more obvious the
Sorkin generation is logical to
modernize a character that is is fine
adjacent the rest doesn't line up with
that kind of monetization nor does it
work for the archetypes that these
characters are nor does the god element
that Zack Snyder does so very well
translate to any of the choices these
characters make also it's kind of boring
and that's the worst part of all for me
is that these characters that are larger
than life that we've loved for years not
only get undermined but we get one of
the best Batman sequences of all time we
get the coolest Warehouse fight sequence
one of the moments I think of with
Batman and then we wait for other things
to happen and I know there's going to be
Zack Snyder fans which I love I love the
world of Zack Snyder overall I love his
way of seeing things I love his
directing style I think he's done a lot
for suicide awareness he's done a lot
for charity he's a good person and so is
his wife they're fantastic but the
fandom is Gonna Come at me and say that
like I'm not smart enough to understand
the Nuance or that's his interpreted
there's a lot of things the fandom does
and I and I love that you're though so
passionate but you being so angry at
people that don't enjoy what you enjoy
makes me enjoy the characters less and
it makes me not want to try to like this
movie so please understand I always try
please understand this is my take on
these characters and please understand
this movie wasn't for me but I do think
there's a lot of reasons that other
people don't like it too and that's not
to say anything disparaging me as Zack
Snyder and Ben Affleck's one of my
favorite Batmans and Henry Cavill is
Superman and that's why I hold it to
such high esteem and why I needed it to
be more get the [ __ ] out of my house
I said it
this this video is terrible
BBS I'm sorry I'm sorry fans of BBS
can't kill Jimmy Olsen off screen you
can't do it all right you lovelies this
next one has been disowned both by the
director and its star and I think most
of the studio doesn't work there anymore
I'm gonna let you know how I feel about
Batman and Robin you give me George
Clooney who is an inherently great Bruce
Wayne and then you give him bat nipples
as Batman do you expect him to stay
afloat that's not gonna happen you give
me a great performance in one movie with
Jerry O'Connell as Robin and then you
don't let him be the Boy Wonder in the
next movie he still has the same Arc
what is that choice and then Alicia
Silverstone fresh off a clueless and
they neuter her character she just shows
up to be like somehow both a damsel in
distress and a super heroine because all
of her dialogue is like and it doesn't
let Alicia Silverstone be that girl and
most of all perhaps the craziest thing
is Joel Schumacher is one of my favorite
directors of all time Lost Boys is one
of the greatest spectacle films ever
made and phone booth shows what he can
do contained he can do both things
Batman is just neon lights and selling
McDonald's toys and they let you know
that they accept that he takes out a
breath that credit card at the beginning
they make Bane a Mindless henchman Bane
is an intellectual equal to Batman and
they make him a thumb and then they make
Mr Freeze a series of jokes I think Uma
Thurman knew what movie she was in she's
doing some strange Transatlantic accent
where she's just having a good time I
feel like they made both Adam West's
Batman and a commercial and none of it
worked and let's talk about Arnold
Schwarzenegger with the puns uh Arnold
is an incredible actor with a very
specific Ness I don't know why they
decided that specific Nest was only
gonna have puns Mr Freeze is a love
story his wife and him is this
passionate tale of being a villain for
the sake of saving your love I remember
Norma freeze in that movie I don't
remember him loving her I vaguely
remember at the end some Icy tears it
hurts the characters it hurts the actors
it hurt the director and it hurt us and
it's long
[Laughter]
I'll include this one on the list
because I actually remember almost
leaving the theater and I love the
character of Jonah Hex I am a huge Josh
Brolin fan I am a big Megan Fox fan and
I saw this in theaters once I don't
remember anything except wanting to walk
out and I don't feel that way about a
lot of things so I might revisit it one
day because maybe it's excellent but as
far as my memory serves not for me all
right next up short and sweet cat woman
now this is a movie I only saw once I
saw it in theaters and what's
interesting about Catwoman is
retroactively it's gotten worse having
never seen it again I vaguely remember a
basketball sequence I vaguely remember
Halle Berry trying but what's
interesting is there's sequences post
Oscar win Halle Berry that I remember
aggressively bad acting and so that
hurts for Halle Berry but also this was
the movie That was supposed to spin off
of Tim Burton's Catwoman this was
supposed to be Michelle Pfeiffer in
Catwoman got delayed for years and this
is what they deliver us so it's kind of
insulting to both Oscar winner Halle
Berry and the entire Tim Burton Batman
Mythos and the character of Catwoman so
even though I've only seen it once this
movie just hurts in general alright
let's talk about the one let's talk
about the one the maybe the one that
rules them all the Fantastic Four of it
all I can't fathom a movie that started
as sure of itself that then had a year
Gap and then lost itself more this movie
I heard only rough things about this is
2015's Josh trank Fantastic Four and it
started strong strong enough that I was
like oh I think people were just wanting
to assume negativity it started in 2015
again is deep MCU deep into the DC film
Universe deep into our modern world so I
was like maybe them trying something new
just isn't working no no there's this
moment where there's this one year Gap
and the movie comes back as an entirely
different movie they never really
explain a lot of things they cut a lot
of the things from the Fantastic Four
that we love like the Fantastic car we
know they shot they don't let the actors
who are talented actors get to be the
characters they've shaped and the
dialogue there are some of the most
clunky dialogue that even Michael B
Jordan can't save even Miles Teller who
who makes a movie about drumming one of
the most riveting action films of all
time along with JK Simmons there's
nothing that Kate Mara can do there's
nothing Jamie Bell can do there's
nothing anyone can do in this movie to
make it work and another round of
wasting Doctor Doom Toby Cabell is right
up there with Andy Circus as far as what
makes the plan of the Apes movie tick
along with obviously director Matt
Reeves tobyquel can't make Dr Doom work
in this because they hodgepodge a bunch
of different storylines and don't let
him play a lot of this movie is done
well in pre-production and a lot of the
ideas deliver and then the movie itself
felt like the studio and the director
made two different movies simultaneously
and they released a hodgepodge of both
the X-Men movies are really interesting
in that some of the best comic book
movies of all time come out of the world
of X-Men you got your X2 your Logan your
days of future past but you've also got
X-Men apocalypse a lot of people think
dark Phoenix is worse than X-Men
apocalypse and I can acknowledge where
they're coming from my absolute totally
see that that movie is a rough time but
for me how do you abuse Oscar Isaac's
time like they did in X-Men apocalypse
they covered one of the most talented
actors in so much silicone and face
makeup that he couldn't move apocalypse
is one of the most terrifying characters
in The X-Men mythology he grows to Great
sizes he's got this incredible Legacy of
of evolving they didn't use apocalypse
apocalypse is just a dude from Egypt in
this movie and it it's Oscar Isaac not
getting to be Oscar Isaac not getting to
use his talents and it brings back Brian
Singer who personal things aside is
someone that was associated with the
X-Men for quite some time someone that
had shaped the world of the X-Men and it
felt like he forgot how to make an X-Men
movie at no point did I feel like I was
watching X-Men I felt more than ever
that I was watching Brian singer's band
of mutants and that's okay if it fits
the narrative but this movie I only saw
it once and that's the only X-Men movie
I've only seen once and I don't remember
a lot going going on in it because it
never felt like it brought me in it also
wasted storm and there's just no excuse
in wasting storm a second time because
this is bringing in a new storm and it
still didn't work to me the reason is
worse than dark Phoenix is the villain
and the waste of Oscar Isaac and this
cast is incredible so you can't have
James McAvoy Jennifer Lawrence Michael
Fassbender Oscar Isaac Nicholas Hull Ty
Sheridan Sophie Turner Evan Peters and
not use them and they somehow managed
Nightcrawler was fun though so that was
that was nice also the last 10 seconds
are the only time we've ever seen the
X-Men in their suits how do you give us
all movie and then give us X-Men suits
as a tease to get ripped it hurts all
right first up we got to talk about one
of the all-time most discussed how did
this happen movies and that is X-Men
Origins Wolverine now this movie does
have some Merit but when you look at it
overall how does a movie manage to waste
one of the best castings of all time
Hugh Jackman as Wolverine is incredible
and this movie actually ended up tanking
other movies there was going to be an
X-Men Origins Magneto which turned into
a lot of the coolest sequences with
Michael Fassbender in another movie this
movie had and wasted not just Ryan
Reynolds as Deadpool which if things
hadn't worked out down the line we would
have lost one of the great comic book
movies but it also wasted and never got
to come to fruition Taylor Kish as
Gambit this movie had a crazy cast a
real odd series of choices Kevin Durant
is like an in-shaped dude they cast him
as blob will I am's here why we don't
know there's a sequence where there's
snicting but it's like the worst CGI
I've ever it looks like 90 CGI in a
movie in the 2000s and the worst part
for me was the movie sacrificed story at
no point was I invested in the live
Schreiber Wolverine relationship except
in the opening credits the opening
credits of this movie are some of the
most beautiful opening credits I've ever
seen in my life and they tell the story
I wanted X-Men Origins Wolverine to be
the origin of Wolverine is just the
credits and the rest is this odd
hodgepodge of of weapon x and these
other mutants and they tried to make it
a team movie while also being a
Wolverine movie and the thing that hurts
me is it sacrificed comic book Integrity
acting integrity and story Integrity for
a lot of really flashy sequences that
they didn't even seem to finish so I
look for the best and this one it'll
look pretty hard this one this one hurts
alright you lovelies uh this was a rare
experience of me being somewhat negative
is not how I like to be you guys know I
love art but I also so do you think that
if we're going to hold things to a
certain standard sometimes we need to
look at the negative in order to see the
positive more positively so these are
movies that I don't think are worthless
that I don't think are bad you shouldn't
be mad at but I do think they are
disappointing and on a scale of 1 to 100
something has to be in that bottom so
that's what this list was discuss below
come at me with your bvs hot takes find
me on Tick Tock so you can yell at me if
you yell at me and don't subscribe it
still does Drive the algorithm so yell
at me on Tick Tock is what I'm asking
that's all I ask all right we'll be back
with more videos just like this I
appreciate each and every one of you
rejects like subscribe comment let me
know what of these you think wasn't
disappointing I mean let me know if
there was any I missed talk to you soon
foreign